it's show time
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and unfortunately it's
all good and things must come to an end
as naomi is better called soul now over
but the crap puns on the show are all
saddened and too the finale is here and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down going through what
happens and also the easter eggs in it
also if you want to support the show we
just launched a better call paul t-shirt
over at our shop zero edition which will
be linked below if you need a spoiler
then your chumps know who to call and i
hope you head over there to pick up this
limited run t-shirt massively supports
the channel means i can buy myself a
golden toilet and it also helps videos
like this get made now last week we saw
marion discovering the truth about jean
through saul's old commercials even
though she ended up calling the police
she still probably liked and subscribed
and this led to jimmy going on the run
once more the preview had his focusing
on his ditched car from earlier in the
series and over the top of this we could
hear him desperately trying to get
himself a new identity
now they sort of spliced two scenes
together for that with the hoover call
almost being a sort of what if that we
never actually see play out however the
car is there which is very important to
how we open things up these calls were
put in place when people wanted to get a
new identity and now gene gets caught a
lot faster than we thought this idea of
identity is very important to bear in
mind we finally see jimmy rest on one
come the culmination of the show and for
once he does the right thing now the
colour also gave a clue to what time
period we'd be in and this is actually
where we start things off we open with a
flashback to season five's episode
bagman and catch mike and jimmy in the
desert this was one of the standout
episodes in the series and this entry
very much feels like a time machine trip
with us getting several cameos in it
such as mike marie walt bill oakley
chuck and a couple of other big
characters time machines are a major
talking point too and we see jimmy
talking about them with mike and walt
before chuck picks up the book by h.g
wells this opening is a great way to
start us off and after finding a water
tank both jimmy and mike discuss regrets
the future and it's basically just an
introspective look at the characters i
love how jimmy's water has a
suspiciously yellow tint to it and you
might remember that saul actually drank
his own
during the bagman episode now these time
machine conversations that appear
throughout all take place at pivotal
points in his life and they're very much
intersections in which we see how his
regrets change
jimmy says he wants to take the 7
million investor in crypto sorry take
the 7 million spend six of it on
building a time machine and use the
other million to go and get rich he then
asks mike what'd he do if he had one and
he says he'd go back to march 17th 1984
aka the day that he took his first bribe
this had a massive impact on the
character as not only did it lead him
down the road to becoming a criminal but
it also led to the death of his son matt
he also says he'd go forward to see how
people were doing clearly referring to
his family and those he cares about
jimmy on the other hand is all about the
dough and he'd rather go back in time
and invest the other million into warren
buffet's berkshire hathaway it's very
much just the fantasy case of using a
time machine to go back and win the
lottery because all that jimmy cares
about is his money any normal person
stuck in this situation would have a lot
of things they'd change but at this
point he's so materialistic that he
believes wealth is the key to happiness
from here we cut to the titles
[Music]
in this we can catch the isotopes air
freshener from jeff's cab and this was
also something that very much led to
gene's downfall had he not gotten the
cab he probably would have been stuck as
the manager of a cinnabon but it gave
him an avenue where he went back to old
habits i also view this as being the
moment that jimmy was caught as it set
up the dominoes that led to everything
falling apart we then jump immediately
to the other side of last week with us
even hearing the door closed behind him
as he bolts out of marion's she
describes his car and also the direction
that he's going in he grabs everything
he can from his home and i love how he
has a stack of flip phones but up in his
cupboard not only is this a really cool
nod to him selling phones earlier in the
series but it also shows just how
prepared that he is in case it all goes
up jimmy ends up trying to call out to
my man the hoover guy but unfortunately
he messes up and he gets caught now
often when you hear a criminal
masterminds being captured you'll hear
how they're found in some of the worst
circumstances trying to evade the law
this is very much the case with jimmy
who due to his confession will be
labeled as having one of the biggest
drug empires in america he's found in a
dumpster after failing to escape and him
stooping to the death shows how far he's
fallen from his mansions and sexy suits
now in some of the best foreshadowing
i've ever seen episode one in the season
actually start off with a shot of his
cardboard cut out being put into a
dumpster it really shows the attention
to detail that the series carries and
how it sets things up far in advance i
love this moment and it gives me chills
going back to watch this to see how it
hinted at what was to come
[Music]
now jimmy's downfall is also echoed on
the commercials that we see the police
watching we can hear his over-the-top
bravado narration about how he can get
anyone out of jail whilst we see him
looking at what would normally be a
one-way ticket he gets his one phone
call and he uses it to contact cinnabon
to tell them that they're gonna need a
new manager got lots of flashes here of
gus calling to make sure los poyo
somanos had a manager in place after he
was shot and it's nice that they show
the similarities in the characters when
they were at their lowest points now
jimmy demands another phone call after
seeing a carving about a lawyer doing
doing what and he reaches out to bill
oakley better call bill spinoff coming
soon baby guarantee it now as we saw
earlier in the season he's now switched
sides to become a defense attorney he
ends up taking jimmy's case and i think
it's great how seoul sells him on how
big it'll be for him bang bang he's
taken down a corridor in curves and this
moment beautifully parallels when he's
escorted to the court now at this point
we get a cameo by marie and the
authorities basically want to throw the
buck at him initially he's facing life
plus 190 years but saul comes out on top
he's initially offered a deal of dirty
but he asks for marie to come in after
referring to her ashrae's widow really
tragic way to see her labelled like this
and watching her talk about hank and
steve gomez is really heartbreaking to
watch reminds you of how much they were
really the good guys and how hank would
always come in with a smile and a joke
even in the darkest times
i mean i miss you so so much
now she says i've sold it at all for the
money further linking back to the first
time machine conversation she's clearly
devastated but still twists things so
that he's seen as a victim just like her
it's incredible watching him go to work
and he mentions the name mayhew which
was the surname of badger from breaking
bad saul talks about being taken to the
desert manny basically spins her to say
that he feared for his life the entire
time he also touches upon big moments
from breaking bad such as the 10 men
being murdered in prison at the same
time and also brings up dan from the
series the prosecutor asks him if he
thinks that jiri are gonna buy this but
he smiles and says
one
all i need is one
now it turns out that the prosecutor has
never lost a case before and this has
given him not only an ego but also the
fear that the first l is right around
the corner he's well aware that there's
potential that jimmy can drop this sub
story in court and win one of them round
though marie doesn't want them to
negotiate he ends up working with jimmy
and they cut his sentence down to seven
years jimmy is so in control of the
entire thing he even picks not only his
prison but also the wing that he'll be
on he chooses the only federal
institution with a golf program and
brings up bernie madoff in case you
don't know bernie was the ex-chairman of
the nasdaq stock exchange and he also
made off with the biggest ponzi scheme
in history totalling in at a whopping 64
billion dollars
compose myself now jimmy so bad now
jimmy will do anything to avoid gen pop
and this is important to bear in mind to
show what he's sacrificing in the end he
gets too arrogant though and in order
for more stuff like ice cream he says
he'll offer up info on how it's death
however they reveal like him already
gave everything up which sweeps jimmy
off his feet from here we cut to walt
and jimmy just before they were shifted
off to their new lives in the case of
both they ended up coming back and we
also get a time machine conversation
here while at one point looks at his
watch which was gifted to him as a
present by jesse and breaking bad this
is a tag heuer monaco that was given to
the monaco grand prix winner in 1969 it
was also worn by steve mcqueen's
character in the 1970 film le mans and
it has a lot of history attached to it
now the one walt has is a 2004 reissue
and he showed it to skyler saying that
the man who tried to kill him once ended
up giving him as a present and this show
that she would forgive him one day too
here it's used in a number of ways to
show how long they've been waiting to
tying with the time machine and it's got
some really nice symbolism to it jimmy
wants to run the thought experiment
again but walt wants to cut the bs and
he disregards time travel as being
scientifically impossible he realizes
that saul just wants to talk about
regrets and he brings up gray matter
walt blamed his old pals for kicking him
out the company because of how rich he'd
end up becoming this mind state very
much explains why he ends up tormenting
them in the finale of breaking bad as he
sees them as artfully removing him solon
leaps to his feet and starts
brainstorming a plan of how he could
have helped but he's quickly shut down
the questions then turn to jimmy and he
brings up how he slipped once and hurt
himself and you could say yeah he was
slipping jimmy
come on that that was good anyway this
leads walter saying so you were always
like this
from here we go to jimmy on the plane
still using his mouth to get what he
wants and he finds out about what kim
gave up he also discovers that cheryl
got the info too so she can now open up
a civil suit this gets jimmy's brain
spinning and he says that he's got one
more thing to trade on kim go to her
back at the lunch table with her
co-workers and it's clear that she's
just not happy she ends up walking out
of her job and we follow her as she
volunteers at a pro bono love him though
it's not much it shows that she's slowly
back on the road to becoming her old
self again
but this is crushed when suzanne calls
her to tell she may be implicated in the
new proceedings really devastating
watching her learn this and i was kind
of worried that kim's life could end up
being destroyed too she very much had
her redemption arc can handed over
everything on howard so seeing that
things could get worse was really
nerve-wracking and we see saul rock up
in the shiniest suit he could find
looking like his old sleazeball self
however the guild starts to wash over
him as he sees kim and marie and this
very much plays into his next move he
goes under the name saul goodman and we
watch as he goes off into his sub story
after the judge asks why he's getting
off so lightly this is verbatim to how
he said it in the prosecution office and
it's all clearly an act however he
quickly shifts gears and he starts lying
to the court in order to take the fall
he says he was the one who helped build
up world's strong empire and says that
he lied about kim's involvement because
he wanted her to come to court we saw
how he tried to save her with lalo and
this is very much the same thing here
with him saving the person he loved was
trying not to cry watching my dude doing
the right thing and he does it to make
sure that kim is okay now he next brings
up howard and his voice cracks as he
credits kim for starting over again and
actually doing the right thing and
handing herself in we then get some
great iconography here with a focus on
the exit sign overhead and he goes off
to talk about chuck and how he hurt him
he destroyed the law for chuck which led
to him ending his own life and he
finally takes responsibility for it the
scene then gives us a chuck flashback to
jimmy helping him out whilst he still
had his electricity phobia chuck tells
him that if he doesn't like where he's
heading that is no shame in going back
and changing things which very much
plays into the fall that he takes here
chuck picks up his copy of the time
machine and he then goes to bed now this
book also popped up in episode 1 of this
season and we could see it as the
mansion got raided it's such amazing
foreshadowing of what was to come and
jimmy very much used his confession as a
way to go back and change things though
not literally a time machine it
corrected some of his regrets and we
watch as he's taken to a terrible prison
one of the other prisoners recognizes
that he saw goodman and though he
corrects this to jimmy the legend lives
on the entire bus starts a chant that
brings a sad smile to jimmy's face and
inside the prison we cut to him flipping
dough the scene very much here resembles
the way that the stuff in cinnabon was
shot showing how no matter what path he
took he still would have ended up doing
this really poetic and we watch as he's
called out to me kim this scene mirrors
how they'd meet in the car park and
share cigarettes and we even get some
similar iconography to that the scene
genuinely gave me goosebumps throughout
it with its long pauses and you can feel
how much they really care about each
other but how they know they'll never
get their happy ending the flame lights
up in another burst of colour showing
how this old flame hey brings the color
back into his life we learned that jimmy
is now doing 86 years but with good
behavior who knows now obviously he's
not going to get that much time off his
sentence so it's very bittersweet he's
still going to spend the rest of his
life in jail and sadly i think that
jimmy knows it however he sees her on
the outside going off to now live her
life free of the torment that she could
have faced jimmy shoots his gun fingers
at her as she departs
and i'm not
crying
now anyone who's had a breakup where you
just want the other person to be happy
can relate a lot to the sorrow displayed
here and that closes out better call
saul and what was a fitting but also
devastating end of the show i think we
all knew that jimmy will get his
comeuppance but we can take some solace
in knowing that at least kim will be
okay now as for my thoughts on this
series i think that better call saul
always had a difficult job because it
was obviously a prequel slash sequel to
one of the best tv shows of all time
well they managed to do what so many
others failed to and at points i
actually think this was better than
breaking bad the early seasons are good
but i think it takes a couple of them
before we really get into what made the
show must watch raz here had hit the
ground running for me early on and
maintained a consistent level throughout
the final season has been no different
and it's arguably had the most impactful
moments from the entire series playing
out almost back to back at points there
was of course nacho's death howard's
lalo the breakup of kim and jimmy gene
going back to his old ways and several
big moments that made this an almost
masterpiece and storytelling at points
now i've often said that prequels are
difficult to do because we already know
where this story eventually ends up
however whereas most fail to utilize
this better cool soul does because we
worry that our favorite characters might
die and that will explain why they're
not in breaking bad on top of this
there's also so many great performances
and memorable characters you can pretty
much pick out any member of the cast and
chances are he'll have hit a home run at
some point the actors behind this show
really sold everything and there were so
many moments where so little was spoken
but it spoke so much to what the
characters were going through that's why
i really loved it and why i think this
series has been one that i'll probably
go back to and re-watch because of the
quality it delivered sadly it's all over
now but i hope you enjoyed our
breakdowns on the second half and
hopefully i'll see you around on the
channel for more coverage on our other
shows we are in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the finale we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers you want to
email us to watch them make sure you
check out brighton of westworld which
will be linked on screen right now we
went over the full finale talking about
all the things in it and uh yeah what
could be happening next time which i'm
not even sure if i'm right but it's
worth discussing anyway if not then
thanks for sticking through the video i
hope you have a great week and uh yeah
take care yourself peace